let's talk about the Quinn acento
question at the end of every three who
won who won 83 Colin I mean the games
that spoke to me were more show more by
Playstation but I still say the biggest
announcement was for Microsoft backwards
compatibility because I think that's a
significant it's a it's a step towards
you know opening up a thousand new games
potentially on Xbox one and I think
that's a huge announcement and I think
that's a direct shot across the bow at
Sony too so I was most intrigued by that
announcement but in terms of games I
mean horizon in the last guardian spoke
to me I think more than sure enough or I
know you're when Uncharted 4 came on
Colin put his head down he's like I
already know I love uncharted 4 I don't
need to pre know and see if I want to
say never again real I was talking to so
II know you gonna come see and I'm like
no and they're like what like there's
like almost a Fenton you know offended
I'm like no no it's a compliment I'm
sure it's going to be great I'm good I
don't need to yeah yeah yeah just just
show it to me when it's in my hands to
the final you know the final build of
the game yeah until then I'm good fair
enough and same what what was what was
making you feel feel good this year
oh there's a lot that was in that entire
Nintendo booth that's the thing though
you know I'm a Nintendo fanboy said it a
million times and you guys know that you
know that well and I am looking forward
to so many of their games Yoshi's woolly
world starfox Mario maker oh my god i'ma
put so much time into those games but I
can't say that in 10 don't want it this
year yeah the direct thing what about
that Metroid Prime game finally Nintendo
they could have won it for me if there
was a big surprise and they didn't know
about if there was just something to
like really look forward to in the
distant future you know I because I want
that hint I want that like oh it's okay
guys we're gonna be okay and it didn't
happen
I gotta go with Playstation man it's
like walking around their booth there's
so many games that I'd want to play
there's so many games that are just
coming out and they even though the
smaller ones the bigger ones people just
seeing journey again yeah 1080 60 it
looks great beautiful so they still
didn't have an answer for that though
right they were just like hey journeys
still here and it's awesome but we don't
know when that's coming and yeah seen
that before
Kevin Coyle is walking off with all the
kind of funny equipment thank you
baggage Grayson's got our bags to
goodbye everybody you'll never see them
again I know
why do we let the the PA part-time guy
take Nick oh hey what's the best thing
you say I can't see you so yeah that's
okay
you tell yourself I think you know I
think it's a toss-up between Microsoft
and Sony this year I think they both had
really really really strong conferences
for all the reasons no I'm not gonna go
ahead and reiterate what you guys have
said I only got a chance I don't think
it's fair that I voted I only got a
chance to stumble around Sony's booth
for about five minutes and then
Microsoft I looked over and like it's
too far it was a bad house over there I
mean they're pros yes I know it's guy
Craig we've got so far we've come too
far but no I might give the slight edge
to Sony as well yeah I mean literally
you know I'm not a huge Sony fanboy like
some people that I know but when the
Last Guardian you know when you saw that
the feather dropping and the Last
Guardian was shown and the look on like
Colin's face specifically right you
can't you can't take that away that was
magical no real good that's a that's and
that to me is you know it's real good
good that's me it's important right
because you know video games are
obviously a form of entertainment but
there's a fair amount of showmanship
that goes into this yeah you do have to
make something not for lack of a better
term like there has to be a little magic
behind it right it can't just be
paint-by-numbers a lot of the time
especially at e3 exactly what we all
look forward to all year exactly and I
feel like Sony really gets that I feel
like they really try and have a lot of
hard not to take anything away from
Microsoft and Nintendo but I feel like
Sony came came with it this year yeah
Microsoft ever started showing as well
as Colin was saying as well Greg can I
even ask should I even ask I mean I
still think it was a really really close
race between Sony and Microsoft in terms
of a and I think you making Casey that
one way or the other the one I think the
people who I lean towards Microsoft
because I think theirs was more about
changing the perception of who they were
right they come out there about games
just games if we have an announcement
it's directly influencing games it's
backwards compatibility and that's
really the thing I think that spoke
about this III was companies established
companies trying to change the messaging
right yeah Microsoft changing their
messaging gorilla coming out and be like
we're more than kill zone totally like
here's fun beautiful thing that
everyone's going to be interested in
even the EA like we had Peter [ __ ]
right and Peter Moore was talking about
unravel
being like it's a game that maybe we
break even on but we make enough money
on FIFA we make enough money on Matt and
we need to take those chances you want
to be the company we want to be and
that's great to hear people say totally
and there's some great little signs
around here as well yeah obviously had
like a company-wide ideology to be like
you know what we need to get better at
female characters into our games and
they've done that across the board as
well and so PlayStation for you in terms
of games sure I mean like they had the
more games that spoke to me but that's
just who I am I mean the Microsoft
conference - felt like it was like
here's a game that's for alfredo and
then here's the game for alfredo here
zebra Greg whereas Sony was way packed
in the beginning I was super interested
in but even at the end I the one thing I
keep criticizing them for is that did
you get to go see the Uncharted demo
behind closed door about it from a bunch
of people when the Uncharted demo closed
out the conference I was waiting for the
moment the you know the Bruce dropped
the controller moment like last of us
like the PSX demo and it didn't come in
NZ okay it's more than charted great and
then you went up in that demo as soon as
it picks back up gets awesome and insane
this different camera angles in motion
and like it looks like a next-gen
uncharted it looks like what you're
expecting what you want
I guess not even expect where as what I
saw Monday night was what I expected
yeah mine closed doors is what I wanted
and if they would have done that entire
demo on stage knocked off another
trailer or something that they would
there would be no debate there'd be no
debate who won t three-finger Scott you
might see it out at Gamescom remember
and maybe in the next couple of weeks
and for me I'm gonna throw a little
curveball I think Bethesda knocked it
out of the park
are you kidding me like it's the first
time they've done it software software
can go either way like squares one was
okay EAS was kind of you know a little
bit rough yeah so like for them to come
on and not only be like okay this is our
first time we're gonna do this but we're
gonna have like slobberknocker after
slobberknocker doom I'm not totally sold
on yeah but I was great to see it and I
think seeing dishonored is fantastic as
well but [ __ ] me man fallout 4 what are
we doing I'm gonna make some awesome
twitch.tv slash kind of funny things I'm
gonna have a great time that's what I'm
doing here's the last thing about about
Bethesda that I liked is that I don't
think they're gonna do that again I
don't think there's gonna get the
conference again
and that's what I like that all this
stars aligned you know it was ready and
arcane was ready and and their internal
studio but that you know but that's the
game studios they're all internal
suitors but Bethesda Game Studios was
ready so the stars aligned and I think
they just disappear next year and I
totally think that's awesome
they had a mic shot they're like you
knew what was coming when they said that
there is no offense to Bethesda but I
hope to god they don't make an annual
thing out of this because adding another
day to e3 is killing me right dead no
matter what that's the thing like we
know we got to this point where we were
deciding on our game of the show and we
went around and nobody mentioned fallout
and Chloe's like you remember fallout
happening right and we're like yeah but
it was expected you know I mean like
ether he's always about this surprise
and what you didn't see coming you know
II mean so for Fallout to have led what
they're coming and this is gonna happen
then we see it and it's more fallout
which is like awesome then upgrades in
this I know it's not exactly the same
yeah but it's similar enough where
you're like that's exactly what I want
that's probably gonna be game of the
year great but like for this right now
like what's got us the most hope for
wide-eyed totally III 2015 ended up in
quite the barn burner at 2015 for video
games it's gonna be pretty great as well
we've got six months of awesome stuff
coming on and thank you so much kind of
funny for joining with us thank you hey
this year our game spot thank you so
much Evan who watch thank you so much
heaven is watching us right here let us
do this crazy nonsense yeah let's let's
start out drinking later on and relax a
lot of drinking yeah we got some video
games to play over the next couple of
months